INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
DATA 2100 students.
We're going to jump into this
in-class assignment using
while loops and
input validation.
As a reminder, if
you have not already
watched all the
videos in this module,
please do so so that this
in-class assignment will
make a lot more sense to you,
as the textbook and the lecture
videos really provide
that foundation.
And then we apply it here
in this in-class assignment.
Also, if you have not tried this
in-class assignment on your own,
please try it.
And then come back.
And see, ooh, do
I understand this?
Or do I have
questions about that?
And we can work
through it together.
Let's jump into this
in-class assignment.
So you'll notice that
when you click on
the link up above with
this in-class assignment,
you are prompted--
this is basically,
if you want to think
about this as the template
for the whole class.
But if you want to
actually have your changes
be saved, be able to turn this
in, click on Copy to Drive.
And then I'll need to sign
in to my Google account
really quickly.
You might need to as well.
I've heard some
issues with Safari not
allowing you to print as a PDF.
So if you need to use
Google Chrome, please do so.
I tend to use Google Chrome.
And it works just fine when
we need to print this to a PDF
at the end.
So we are going to apply
fundamental skills in Python
here today.
You're going to be turning
in two different files.
You'll turn in the PDF
version of this document
once you have created
and ran every program
so that you can see the output.
And then you'll also save the
Jupyter Notebook file as well.
So each program
listed should perform
all of the subitems
listed under that program.
So program number
one here asks us
to write a program that
fulfills the below requirements.
Ask the user to
input an integer.
If they enter an integer,
multiply their integer by 2.
Then output the
value of their entry,
multiply by 2 to the user.
If their entry is
not an integer,
tell them of their error.
And the program
should not crash.
So as a reminder, there's
really two ways in this class
that we're going to focus on
input validation, one using
while loops, where we oftentimes
also use an if statement
to continue asking people to
continue repeating the program.
And until they enter
something valid,
continue trying to
enter something.
But when we're looking at
validating the type of data,
we're generally going to
look at, try and accept.
So the content of
their entry, we're
going to be using more
while loops, try and accept
focuses on the type
of their entry.
So let's go ahead.
And we're going to ask the
user to input an integer.
And then we'll go ahead and
move forward from there.
So let's ask the user
to enter an integer.
We'll say x is equal to input.
Please enter an integer.
So we're going to ask our
user to enter an integer.
And then if they
enter an integer,
multiply their integer by 2.
Then output the value of
their entry multiplied
by 2 to the user.
So let's go ahead-- and
we're not going to look at--
let's not look so far yet
at the try and except.
Let's just write this as
though we were not looking
at if they entered integer.
So let's multiply their
integer by 2 and output to them
the value of their entry.
So I'll say print
thanks for your entry.
your entry multiplied by 2 is--
and then, again, we're going to
use our f strings here and say,
your entry multiplied by 2 is.
And then place the
value of the variable
x multiplied by 2 right here,
then our curly brackets.
So let's go ahead and
run this and try it out.
I'm going to press Play.
Sometimes, the first time we
run a code cell in our Jupyter
Notebook, it takes a minute.
So let's say 7.
And I hit Enter.
It says, thanks for your entry.
Your entry multiplied
by 2 is 77.
Ooh, that's not quite right.
So let's think about--
OK, why is that not quite right?
So if we do x multiplied by 2--
hmm-- is 77.
So it's actually treating this--
interestingly enough, it's
treating x as a string.
Because every time we input
something, it's a string.
And it's basically just doubling
that string and getting 77.
So instead, we
actually say, hey,
let's first off convert
their entry to be an integer.
As a reminder, input is always
interpreted as a string.
So let's say x is equal
to integer form of x.
So we're going to convert
their entry to be an integer.
Now, let's run it again.
Please enter an integer.
I say 7.
I hit Enter.
Thanks for your entry.
Your entry multiply by 2 is 14.
There we go.
So I was expecting you to
throw more of an error,
be a little bit more
frustrated with this.
But it actually just doubled it.
But now, let's run this again.
And now that I've converted
their entry to be an integer,
let's say that I type in 7.
And I hit Enter.
Well, it automatically
throws me an error.
So this is actually an error.
And my program is crashing.
And it says, ooh,
invalid literal for int
with base 10-- seven.
So basically, what this means is
that it's saying I can't convert
that word "seven" to be an
integer because it's not
an integer.
So we get this.
Our program crashes.
So what we need to do now is
we want to try and convert
their entry to be an integer.
And if it works, great.
We can use our print function.
If it doesn't, then
maybe we're going
to notify our user instead of
just having the program crash.
So let's go ahead.
And up here, we're going to ask
our user to input an integer.
And then I want
to try and convert
their entry to be an integer.
So let's try and do that.
And if that works, then I
want to print, nice job,
you entered a print.
Thanks for your entry.
Your entry multiplied
by 2 is blank.
So as long as this works,
the print statement will run.
If anything in this try
block throws an error,
then my except block
will run instead.
So if the entry is
not able to be--
if the user's input is not able
to be converted to an integer,
then this print will not run.
Automatically, it
skips everything
beneath it in the try block
and runs the except block.
And we'll say, if there is
an error, then this will run.
So let's go ahead and say print,
ugh, that was not an integer.
So let's go ahead
and run this now.
So I'm going to type
the word "seven again.
I'll hit Enter.
It says, ugh, that
was not an integer.
So it returns something to me.
It didn't just crash.
It returned that print statement
to me, which is so powerful.
So that's the beauty
of a try and accept,
is it's going to try
and convert this.
If it won't convert, then
my except block runs.
However, if it does convert,
if I actually type the number 7
and hit Enter, then it
says, thanks for your entry.
Your entry multiplied
by 2 is 14.
So since it was successful,
this conversion was successful.
Then my print
statement ran below it.
And my except block never
ran because there was never
an error that happened.
OK, awesome.
Let's see here if I can get
rid of that little text box.
I'm going to copy
this code in case.
It says, Cannot save changes.
It's being a little funky here.
Oh, I don't know that mine
actually copied to drive.
So I'm going to
copy this code here.
I'm going to click
Copy to Drive.
It's not allowing
me to save changes.
All right, there we go.
Now, it finally
created the copy.
So it just had me log in.
So I'm going to, as always,
name your file Reagan--
name it first name, last name.
Then I'm going to paste
my code here down below.
So you'll see here that
that code did save.
But originally-- so it was
saying, Cannot save changes.
And it had not formally
copied to my personal drive.
So make sure that that
copy to drive goes away.
And then now, you're able to
see that my code has saved.
And now, I'm able to submit
it under my actual name.
All right, awesome.
Now, I want you to write
a program that fulfills
the below requirements.
Ask the user to input
their birth year.
If the birth year is
before your birth year,
then return to the user how
many years older they are.
If the birth year is
after your birth year,
then return to the user how
many years younger they are.
If the user was born
in the same year,
tell them how exciting it is
to be born in the same year.
This program does not need
to keep asking the user
if they input--
the incorrect input.
The program can just end.
So we're not going
to continue asking
them did they enter an
integer, for example.
So we're just going to
write this code here.
You're going to first need to
be able to compare my birth
year with their birth year.
So I'll say, declare
your birth year.
So you can do your
own birth year.
I'm just going to say--
this is not my birth year.
But we'll just
throw it out there.
My birth year is 1992.
And then I want to ask my user
to enter their birth year.
So I'll say user birth
year is equal to input.
Please enter your birth year.
Now, as a reminder, input is
always interpreted as a string.
Are you sick of me
saying that yet?
Because you should be.
Remember, we need to
convert their entry
to be an integer
because that's what we
are anticipating them to enter.
And we're going
to need to compare
their entry of user birth year
to the integer 1992, which
is my birth year.
So then I'm going
to come down here.
And I'll say, if
my birth year is
greater than user birth year--
so if my birth year is greater
than the user's birth year--
so if they are older
than me, do this.
Then I want to print to them--
So if that condition is true,
you are some odd years older
than me.
So I can place here-- again,
let's use my f strings.
And I'm actually going
to do an arithmetic
here with inside this.
And I'll say, you are
blank years older than me.
So I'll say, you are my birth
year minus your birth year years
older than me.
So I'm going to subtract my
birth year minus the user's
birth year to see how many
years older they are than me.
So let's try this out here.
So if my birth year
is 1992, I need
to enter somebody
who's older than me.
o let's say 1990.
So it should output to me that
you are two years older than me
because this condition
will be true.
My birth year is greater
than their birth year.
So now I hit Enter.
Oh, no.
Now, I hit Enter.
I got to click off that.
There we go.
And you are two
years older than me.
Perfect.
So again, this
condition is true.
My birth year is greater
than their birth year.
They are older than me.
And then I say you are my birth
year minus user birth years
older than me.
Perfect.
Now, if that is not true,
then I want to evaluate,
as my code says up above here.
If the birth year is
after your birth year,
then return to the user how
many years younger they are.
So I'll say elif my birth year
is less than user birth year.
So if they are younger
than me, do this.
OK, perfect.
Then I'll print
using my f string.
You are blank years
younger than me.
I'm going to do the similar
thing here, just the opposite.
I'm going to say user birth
year minus my birth year
because their
birth year is going
to be greater than mine if
they're younger than me.
And I'll say my birth year.
Perfect.
You are years younger than me.
Awesome.
Then now, let's try this
out and put somebody here
who's younger than me.
So I'll say 1997 and hit Enter.
And it says you are five
years younger than me,
which is absolutely correct.
Now, finally, if none
of these are true,
if my birth year is not
greater than their birth year,
less than their birth year,
then my else block
will run, which
means if we are the
same age, do this.
As a reminder, else does not
have any conditional expression
after that.
It's just else.
Now, I'll print.
We have the same birth year.
How exciting.
Let's go ahead and run this now.
So please enter your birth year.
Let's try out a few things.
1997, they're going
to be younger than me.
Perfect.
You are five years
younger than me.
Let's put in here 1985.
You are seven years
older than me.
Also good.
Then let's check out
something else here.
And let's say that
they input 1992.
Then it says we have
the same birth year.
How exciting.
Awesome.
So again, here, I'm
looking at users input.
Now, same as above.
But this time, we're going
to do some input validation.
This time, verify that the
user inputs an integer.
If they do not enter
an integer, then
do not let the program crash.
Instead, tell them
of their error.
This program does not need
to keep asking the user
if they input incorrect input.
The program can just end.
So let's grab this
program up above here.
And I can delete out, write
your code for program here, too.
And I'll bleep that out.
So let's copy this
code down to program 3.
So we're going to just continue
iterating upon this code.
And same as above.
But we're just going to
verify that what they enter
is indeed an integer.
So as of right now, if I
was to run this program,
just like the one that I
wrote up above, program 2,
and I enter 1997 and I hit
Enter, then my program fails.
It absolutely fails because
we cannot convert that string
value.
Inputs always
interpreted as a string.
We cannot convert that string
value to be an integer.
So my program just crashes.
So this one asks me to
verify that what they enter
is an integer and to not
let my program crash.
So I'm going to-- now, I'm going
to separate instead of directly
trying to convert their
entry to be an integer,
I'm going to break this
apart a little bit more.
So I'm going to say, after I ask
them to enter their birth year,
then I'm going to try to convert
their entry to be an integer.
And I'll say user birth
year is equal to the integer
form of user birth year.
All right, awesome.
Then I'm going to
indent everything
beneath this try block.
OK, perfect.
So if this is successful,
then this will all run.
And keep in mind here, if we
did have an error within this
if, elif, and else, if
there is an error occurred,
then the except
block will still run.
However, we know that this
if, elif, and else will run.
So we're really
looking at here is,
does their entry
convert to an integer?
If this fails, then
none of this will run.
And instead, my
except block will run.
And it will say print,
you must enter an integer.
So again, if this fails, if my
conversion to an integer fails,
then all of a sudden this
if block will not run.
And instead, my
except block will run.
So now, let's run this.
Please enter your birth year.
And I say 1992.
And I hit Enter.
We have the same birth year.
How exciting.
All right, great.
Now, let's type out
something non-integer.
I'll say 1992 and hit Enter.
And it says you must
enter an integer.
So this try to run, this failed,
skipped all of this if block,
and just ran my accept
whatever was indented
and beneath my accept.
Remember, I told
you in the beginning
as we started to learn how
to program that Python makes
extensive use of indentations.
So you'll notice it says
that everything indented
and beneath this try block.
Everything indented and
beneath this except block.
OK, awesome.
Now, same as above.
But this time, keep asking
them to input an integer
until they actually
input an integer.
So there's a few ways
we could do this.
Truly, there's a lot of ways.
I'm going to do it in one way.
Doesn't mean that this is the--
it definitely doesn't mean this
is the only way.
This is more just--
this is one way to do it.
So I want to--
again, same as above.
But this time, keep asking
them to enter an integer
until they enter one.
So let's go ahead and copy
this down from program 3.
Now, with program 4 here,
we want to keep asking them.
So what I'm going to do--
I know I'm going to
keep asking them.
So I know that I want to keep
asking them to enter their birth
year over and over and over
again until they actually
enter an integer.
So I will say,
while true, meaning
until we hit that break command,
continue asking them for input.
Now, this time, I'm
actually going to remove my
if, elif, and else block.
I'm going to cut that.
So Control-X on my Windows.
And I'm going to paste
that code down below here.
Now, this can be
a little finicky.
So you might have to do
some re-formatting, if you
will, of if, elif, and else.
But it shouldn't be too bad.
So the reason that I brought
this out of my while loop is I
want to say that
while true, meaning
keep asking them until
you hit the break command.
This means keep asking
them to enter their birth
year until they have
entered an integer.
Then we can break out
of this while loop
once they've entered an integer.
And then just my
if block can run.
I don't need to have my
if, elif, and else inside
of my while loop because
it's only going to run when--
or I only want it to run when
they do enter an integer.
So keep asking them until you
hit the break commands slash
they entered an integer.
So what I'm going to
do here is after this--
I'm going to try and convert
their entry to be an integer.
If this succeeds, then
everything else in my try block
will run.
So that means I'm going to
break then out of my while loop.
And then my if block will run.
So remember, everything indented
in beneath the while loop
happens over and over and over
again until we hit that break
command.
Once we leave that while
loop, then everything
left aligned with
that while loop--
you see how that's
left aligned here.
Then that can run.
Once I leave that
while loop, then I
can go back here to
everything left aligned.
So let's go ahead and run this.
It says please enter
your birth year.
And I say 1991.
I hit Enter.
It says you are one
years older than me.
So what this means is that it
tried to convert my 1991 entry.
And it succeeded.
So it broke out
of my while loop.
Then everything left
aligned here ran.
So my if block ran.
And it says that you are
one year older than me.
So this was true.
So then everything indented
and beneath my if ran.
And since my if was
correct, then it
skipped my elif and my else.
So now, let's run this again.
And this time, let's say 1997.
I'm writing out string
type of data here.
And I hit Enter.
Now, this time, it says
you must enter an integer.
So what it did is it said, can
I convert whatever they just
enter to be an integer?
No, I cannot.
That try fails.
So I skip the break command.
And immediately, my
except block runs.
And it says, you must
enter an integer.
Then since I never
hit the break command,
I skipped over it because this
line of code threw an error.
So I skipped over
the break command
and ran that except block.
Then it says you must
enter an integer.
Then it loops back up here to
beginning of the while loop.
And it says, please
enter your birth year.
So that's where
we are right now,
is it's asking me to
enter my birth year again.
Let's say 2,000.
2,000.
Now, I run this.
It says you must
enter an integer.
So again, that conversion
failed, skipped
the break command.
Print, you must enter an
integer, was returned to me.
And it's still waiting for me.
My program is still
running because that's
waiting for more input.
Now, if I enter in
1991 and I hit Enter,
it says you are one
years older than me.
So this is working just
fine at this point.
But you can see here, we built
out this program kind of step
by step throughout these
different programs.
We just built on
different capabilities.
So you'll see this periodically
throughout as we go,
that we just-- again, always
start with what you know.
Am I asking for input?
Input's always
interpreted as a string.
Can I convert it
to be an integer?
And again, with
the try and except,
it's really focusing on
don't let that program crash.
If they enter the
wrong data type,
don't let that program crash.
All right, everybody, thanks
so much for your hard work.
As a reminder, go
File, Download.
And then download this
Jupyter Notebook file
with the file extension IPYNB.
And then submit that.
As well as you'll also need
to submit the PDF version.
So you go File, Print
down at the very bottom.
You can't see on my screen.
And then say Microsoft
print to PDF.
Now, again, keep
in mind, if this
is throwing any errors
for you on that printing,
you may need to switch over into
Google Chrome instead of Safari.
But you're going to
submit those two files.
And make sure that you've
ran all of these programs
because that PDF
is going to show
all of your output,
which is what
we'll use also in our grading.
So thanks, everybody, for
being an awesome class.
Take care.